Let’s review aldehyde and ketone reactivity,
because this will tell us a lot about how
and why enols and enolates form.
Here is acetone, a simple ketone.
Oxygen is more electronegative than carbon,
so the oxygen that are shared in this bond
are pulled toward the oxygen; they're whizzing
around in this bond but because oxygen attracts
the electrons more we get a dipole in this
molecule.
We can also show a resonance form for acetone
that puts a formal negative charge on oxygen
and a positive charge on carbon.
This contributes significantly to the carbonyl
group’s reactivity.
So, when an electron rich atom bonds to a
carbonyl, it's going to do so at the delta
positive carbon atom.
In a Grignard reaction, the Grignard carbon
has lots of negative charge concentrated on
it.
So, the nucleophilic carbon of the Grignard
reagent is going to attack at the electrophilic
carbon atom and pushing the electrons up onto
oxygen Then a second stage of the reaction
is carried out, where dilute acid is added
to give the oxygen a proton and form an alcohol.
Acid-catalyzed additions of nucleophiles are
also possible with aldehydes and ketones.
Since the oxygen atom of the carbonyl is electron
rich it can attack a proton.
Once it's protonated, the positive charge
on oxygen makes the adjacent carbon atom even
more electropositive.
In the reaction I've shown here, the nucleophile
is one of the oxygen atoms of the molecule
below the arrow, ethylene glycol.
In several steps, we eventually get bonding
of both oxygen atoms of ethylene glycol to
the carbonyl carbon, forming this functional
group, called a ketal.
The dipole in acetone also affects the hydrogen
atoms that are adjacent to the carbonyl.
They feel the pull of the dipole in the molecule,
and consequently become more acidic with a
pKa of 27.
Now, this might not seem too acidic, but compared
to a regular unsubstituted hydrocarbon, which
has a pKa of around 50, this is a substantial
decrease.
The acidity of the alpha protons allows them
to be deprotonated.
Sodium hydroxide can attack the acidic proton,
and we push electrons all the way through
the carbonyl to show how formation of the
anion is stabilized by conjugation.
There is another resonance form that puts
the negative charge on carbon—so an enolate
is a carbon nucleophile.
We went from a compound that undergoes nucleophilic
attack to something that can do the attacking!
A compound with analogous reactivity, called
an enol, can be formed under acid-catalyzed
conditions.
The mechanism begins the same as the acid
catalyzed addition we showed above, where
the electrons on the delta negative oxygen
can attack a proton on sulfuric acid, in this
case.
Protonation of the carbonyl oxygen makes the
alpha hydrogens even more acidic, and they
can be deprotonated.
This is reasonable because the conjugate base
of sulfuric acid is highly resonance stabilized
and isn’t very nucleophilic; typically there's
a bit of water even in the most concentrated
solutions of acid.
So, under acidic conditions, we formed an
enol, which is also a nucleophile.
Now that we’ve looked at how enols and enolates
are formed, let’s look briefly at their
reactivity.
The first reaction we'll look at is alpha
halogenation.
This is going to introduce a halogen atom
at the carbon adjacent to the carbonyl.
We'll carry out this reaction under acidic
conditions, using acetic acid and bromine.
In the first step, our enol is generated.
Then, a lone pair on oxygen can push back
down, allowing the double bond of the enol
to attack bromine, displacing Br minus.
Now, we get a positive charge on oxygen, which
can be deprotonated with acetate, which we
formed when we protonated our carbonyl compound
to form our enol in the first place.
So, why are these alpha halogenated carbonyl
compounds useful?
Well, they're great substrates for SN2 reactions,
and we can displace the bromine with a variety
of nucleophiles.
Here, I’m showing a reaction with dimethylamine
to make an alpha amino compound.
We can also form carbon–carbon bonds using
enols and enolates, which is very important
in synthetic organic chemistry where the goal
is to build up more complex carbon skeletons
from simpler molecules.
To show this alkylation reaction, I’m going
to first deprotonate acetone to form an enolate.
Now, we need a little bit of fancier chemistry
here.
The enolate/enol forming reactions I’ve
shown above are actually in equilibrium when
made with NaOH or sulfuric acid.
But to make this alkylation reaction proceed
with any sort of control, we're going to need
some fancier chemistry here.
We're going to use lithium diisopropylamide,
or LDA, to generate this enolate completely.
LDA has two isopropyl groups and a negative
charge on nitrogen.
This makes it a very hindered base.
So, it can't attack at our carbonyl, as amines
are known to do, instead it's big and bulky
and it can only get at this alpha hydrogen.
we need to generate our enolate completely,
so we’re going to use a special base called
LDA, or lithium diisopropylamide.
It's is also much more basic than sodium hydroxide,
so we can treat our compound with one equivalent
of LDA and generate our enolate completely.
Now, in a second step, we can add in an alkyl
halide.
Since we used up all of our LDA, we don’t
have to worry at all about our base reacting
with the bromide.
The enolate attacks at the electropositive
carbon next to the bromide leaving group,
and our final molecule extends our carbon
chain by three carbon atoms.
This reaction works best with alkyl halides
that are not hindered, so primary alkyl halides
are a good choice for this reaction.
Before we wrap up, I do need to mention that
enolate alkylation has lots of limitations
and, in another lesson, we will go over these
limitations and how to work around them.